TEST.
TEST..
TEST
TEST.ST.
ST.
TEST
TEST.
>>> AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A
TRAVEL.
>> AND THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
MISTAKES THAT ARE MAGNIFIED WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A GAME DOWN
THE STRETCH.
>> AND NOT ALLOWING THE SHOOTER
EVEN AN INCH OF BREATHING ROOM
ON THAT ONE.
>> THAT'S JUST GREAT DEFENSE.
FORCING THE MAN INTO THE
DIFFICULT ATTEMPT.
>> HE DISHES IT TO HENRY.
PASS TO HOPKINS.
>> IT'S JUST WHAT THE DOCTOR
ORDERED HERE.
BOY, HAVE THEY NEEDED HIM HERE
IN THE FOURTH.
>> HE KICKS IT TO HENRY.
THERE'S THE PASS TO HOPKINS.
AND THE OFFICIALS CALL A
TRAVELING VIOLATION.
PASS TO HENRY.
PASS IT TO HOPKINS.
NOW ADAMS.
>> OH, HE FOUND AN OPEN SPACE
FROM MID RANGE.
JUST MAYBE RUSHED HIS RELEASE A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT HE'S GOT THE HOT HAND RIGHT
NOW.
AS LONG AS HE CAN KEEP GETTING
OPEN, THEY HAVE GOT TO KEEP
FEEDING HIM.
>> DISHES IT TO HENRY.
HE LOBS IT UP.
>> REALLY STARTING TO ATTACK ON
THE INTERIOR HERE, SHOWING A
MUCH MORE PHYSICAL PRESENCE HERE
IN THE SECOND HALF.
>> TO THE MIDDLE.
PASS TO HOPKINS.
TO THE WING ON THE LEFT.
HENRY PASSES TO HOPKINS.
HERE'S ADAMS.
THE PASS TO HOPKINS.
>> IT'S NOT EASY TO KEEP HIM
FROM CONVERTING THOSE.
I MEAN, THE "D" HAS TO BE AIR
TIGHT.
HE'S MADE SEVEN OF HIS LAST
EIGHT SHOTS.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
CLUTCH.
THIS IS THE "D" THAT CAUSES
THAT.
THAT'S JUST A LOSS OF
CONCENTRATION THAT TIME.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO LOVE THE
EFFORT.
I MEAN, HE BATTLES JUST AS HARD
ON THE INSIDE AS HE DOES ON THE
PERIMETER.
>> INSIDE.
ADAMS OUTSIDE.
PASSES IT TO HOPKINS.
THERE'S THE DISH TO HENRY.
TO THE INSIDE.
>> HIS INDIVIDUAL EFFORT HAS
BEEN OUTSTANDING TONIGHT.
IT'S HELPED HIM GRAB THE LEAD.
>> HOPKINS, THE PASS TO HENRY.
ADAMS, RIGHT SIDE.
PICKED AWAY.
PASS TO HOPKINS.
>> NOT SHOT FROM OUTSIDE.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
SPREADING THE FLOOR AND GETTING
THEM UP.
>> PASS TO HENRY.
>> AND THAT'S JUST GREAT WORK
THERE, TO GET IN THE SHOOTER'S
SPACE AND THEN GO AND CORRAL
THAT BACKBOARD.
>> THE PASS TO HOPKINS.
OVER TO THE WING.
PASSES IT TO HOPKINS.
>> WELL, WITH THE ROLL HE'S ON
THIS QUARTER, THEY'RE GOING TO
KEEP GOING TO HIM.
AND THEY'LL GET THAT LEAD EVEN
BIGGER.
>> KICKS TO HENRY.
ADAMS SENDS IT BACK.
>> WHEN HE'S AROUND, HE'S
CAPABLE OF COMING UP WITH THESE
BLOCKS.
>> PASS TO HENRY.
>> JUST CALL HIM THE CLOSER.
HE WON'T LET THIS TEAM LOSE.
>> ADAMS, RIGHT SIDE.
HOPKINS, THE PASS TO ADAMS.
PASS TO HENRY.
TO THE LEFT WING.
NOW THE PASS TO HOPKINS.
OH, HE'S GOING UP FOR THE
ALLEY-OOP HERE.
TRYING TO GO FOR AN ALLEY-OOP,
AND EXCELLENT ANTICIPATION THERE
TO STOP IT.
DISHES IT TO HENRY.
STOLEN.
♪
PASSES IT TO NEWTON.
DISHES IT TO WHITE.
LEONARD KICKS TO BODNAR.
WHITE FINDS BOGNAR.
>> IF YOU LET THE LITTLE GUY GET
AIRBORNE BEFORE YOU SLIDE OVER
TO GET HIM OUT, HE WILL AND CAN
EMBARRASS YOU ON THE BOARDS.
>> JACKSON DISHES TO LEONARD.
PASS TO BOGNAR.
WHITE TRYING TO GET OPEN.
JACKSON PASSES TO LEONARD.
NOW WHITE BACK TO WAGNER.
AND THERE'S THE FEED TO LEONARD.
>> HARD TO CATCH UP WHEN YOU
CAN'T HIT SHOTS.
THIS IS A QUARTER HE'D LIKE TO
FORGET.
>> JACKSON KICKS TO LEONARD.
PASSES IT TO WHITE.
>> AND THEY HAVE REALLY GOTTEN
ON TRACK HERE IN THE SECOND
HALF, AFTER THAT SHAKY START.
THE FIELD GOAL PERCENTAGE
STEADILY CLIMBING.
THEY COULDN'T MAKE ANYTHING IN
THAT FIRST BREAK.
AND MEMO TO THE REST OF THE
TEAM -- CONTINUE TO GET HIM THE
BASKETBALL.
HE'S CLEARLY DELIVERING HERE IN
THE FOURTH.
>> LEONARD ON THE WING.
PASS TO NEWTON.
PASS TO WHITE.
BACK TO WAGNER.
INSIDE.
>> HE'S HOT THIS QUARTER.
GETTING THE SHOTS HE WANTS AND
HE'S DELIVERING.
>> NOW THE DISH TO JACKSON.
THERE'S A LOB TO JACKSON, STOLEN
AWAY
NO DOUBT ABOUT THE CONSISTENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO SCORING THE
BASKETBALL FOR HIM TONIGHT.
A REAL NICE LIFT FOR THEIR
OFFENSE.
>> LEONARD FINDS WHITE.
UP TOP, WAGNER.
JACKSON TRYING TO BREAK FREE.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
QUARTER FOR HIM.
>>> INSIDE.
TO THE PAINT.
PASSES IT TO GARRETT.
TO THE INSIDE.
NELSON, THE PASS TO YOUNG.
HERE'S GARRETT.
BACK TO YOUNG.
SENT BACK AND HE GETS IT BACK.
BROWN, OUTSIDE.
>> HE'S UNGUARDABLE.
NOBODY HAS BEEN ABLE TO CONTAIN
HIM HERE IN THE FOURTH QUARTER.
NOW 4 OF 5 FROM THE FIELD.
>> PASS TO GARRETT.
THE EMPHATIC REJECTION.
REJECTED BY YOUNG.
>> NOW, GET THAT OUT OF THERE.
THAT'S ALL TIMING RIGHT THERE.
JRUE HOLIDAY CONTINUING HUSTLE
PLAY.
>> STOLEN BY BROWN.
>> AND HERE IN THE FOURTH, HE'S
CARRYING THIS TEAM RIGHT NOW.
5 OF 7 FROM THE FIELD.
>> NELSON DISHES TO YOUNG.
PASS TO YOUNG.
HE KICKS IT TO GARRETT.
PASS TO NELSON. THAT'S THE KIND
YOU WANT TO SEE ON EVERY
POSSESSION THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
>> AND THERE'S THE PASS TO
GARRETT.
PASS TO YOUNG.
HE DISHES IT TO GARRETT.
INSIDE.
DISHES IT TO NELSON.
AND GARRETT PICKS TO YOUNG.
LOADS IT UP FOR YOUNG.
BROWN, OUTSIDE.
PASS TO NELSON.
BROWN, OUTSIDE.ASS TO YOUNG.
>> TO THE MIDDLE.
REJECTION, AND THAT GOES OUT OF
BOUNDS.
AND THEY RETAIN POSSESSION.
GARRETT, THE PASS TO NELSON.
THAT'S TIPPED.
YOUNG PASSES TO GARRETT.
BACK TO YOUNG.
IT'S STOLEN BY BROWN.
>> AND THERE'S THE PASS TO
RAMSEY.
AND HE LOBS IT UP TOWARD THE
RIM.
>> OH, HE FOUND THE OPEN SPACE
FROM OPEN RANGE.
MAYBE RUSHED HIS RELEASE A
LITTLE BIT.
HE'S PULLING OUT ALL OF THE
TRICKS THIS QUARTER.
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO
STOP HIM.
>> PASS TO RAMSEY, NOW HERE'S
JAMES.
>> THAT'S THE REBOUNDING IN A
NUTSHELL.
BOX OUT AND HOLD YOUR GROUND.
>> AND IT ENDS UP OUT OF BOUNDS,
AND THEY'LL KEEP POSSESSION.
ON THE WING, JAMES.
PASS TO RAMSEY.
DOWN LOW.
MAGNIFICENT REJECTION.
>> AND HE DELIVERS ANOTHER BLOW.
SOMETHING'S GOT INTO HIM THIS
QUARTER.
HE'S CARRYING THEM OFFENSIVELY.
>> PASS TO JAMES.
TO THE WING ON THE LEFT.